françois meylan il est professeur à
l'école de santé publique de
l'université de montréal françois béland
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors triste choqué déçu fâcher
les mots de justin trudeau sont forts la
situation dans les maisons de retraite
au canada c'est une réelle découverte
pour le gouvernement
bon pour commencer il faut bien
comprendre qu'il y a au moins treize
système de santé au canada
dix provinces et trois territoires
les serres les services de santé en
particulier les services de santé que
vous avez chez vous les donner dans les
ehpad sont donc strictement provincial
sont sous juridiction provinciale et non
pas juridiction fédérale
monsieur trudeau peut se choquer mais ce
sont les premiers ministres des
provinces et les ministres de santé des
provinces qui ont la responsabilité de
ces maisons les 5 ch et celle des comme
on les appelle au québec
le saignement en ontario sont aucune
juridiction de l'ontario et ce qui se
passe et en ontario dans d'autres
provinces et se passe autre chose au
québec qu'il ya aussi une situation
difficile mais un peu moins qu'en
ontario
ensuite il s'agit de cinq maisons et
tandis que l'ontario compte au moins une
centaine de ces maisons donc il faut
quand même faire attention à la chose
mais oui c'est vrai il y a de façon
générale une situation difficile dans ce
que l'on appelle encore une fois le ch
et celle des qui est ce qui ressemble
peu la situation au québec ressemble un
peu à celle des ehpad en france
alors comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
expliquer cette situation désastreuse
dans ces maisons de retraite
particulièrement en ontario justement
bon alors notariaux québec ont eu de ces
problèmes de façon beaucoup plus aiguë
que dans d'autres dans d'autres
provinces en colombie britannique par
exemple la situation était beaucoup
moins pénible
et il y a eu des directives qui ont été
suivis et en colombie-britannique nous a
été démis par la santé publique
alors tandis que en ontario et au québec
que ces directives ont été soit ont été
retardés ou peu suivi ensuite il ya
aussi un facteur historique c'est à dire
que et ça ça vaut pour à peu près toutes
les provinces il ya eu une véritable
négligence des ch et celle des est en
général de l'ensemble des services de
soins de longue durée dans toutes les
provinces canadiennes autre chose qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que le régime
canadien de santé c'est à dire ce que
l'on appelle le régime universel et
public de santé au canada n'est public
et universel que pour deux composantes
c'est à dire les services auprès des
médecins et les services donnés dans les
hôpitaux
tout le reste n'est pas couvert par le
régime le régime canadien
le reste est à la volonté des provinces
qui peuvent à ce moment-là investir
comme ils le veulent
administré comme ils le veulent financer
comme elles veulent ces services-là et
de façon générale les provinces ont
abandonné ou du moins ont-elles retarder
les investissements et les réformes
nécessaires et donner de sérieux
nécessaires à tout ce secteur des
services de longue durée aux personnes
âgées services de longue durée qui
comprennent à la fois les services à
domicile un peu là pas si on veut comme
en france ou bien encore les ch et celle
des ou bien les états
françois meylan comment est ce qu'on
peut comprendre que ce soit l'armée qui
étaient envoyés dans ces maisons de
retraite pour pallier à l'absence de
personnel bon alors là c'est une longue
histoire et je pense que ça m'a pris en
quelques mots de passe ont trait aux
arabes de façon très rapide ce qui est
arrivé c'est que le personnel dans ces
établissements de longue durée s'est
trouvé confronté à un problème pour
lesquels elle n'avait il n'avait aucune
préparation
en plus du fait que le conte à virus
s'est répandu très rapidement dans
certaines de ces maisons
le personnel aussi a été affectée il a
été malade et donc du personnel a manqué
certains ont vraiment pris peur de ce
qui les situations sont devenus choquant
dans certaines dans certains
établissements et souvent dans un bon
nombre de citadine de ces établissements
malgré les appels des gouvernements
provinciaux pour que des volontaires des
bénévoles d'autres personnes se
présentent dans les sièges clvc ces
appels ont été entendus mais pas
suffisamment donc que les provinces ont
fait appel à l'armée pour combler les
besoins dans un certain nombre de ces
établissements alors il nous reste très
peu de temps néanmoins une dernière
question une enquête a été ouverte dans
cinq maisons de retraite où l'armée est
actuellement présente
qu'est ce que l'on peut attendre de
cette enquête moi c'est inquiète
il y aura il y aura des enquêtes
un différend de différents types dans au
moins deux provinces ont à la fois au
québec et en ontario
il ira il y aura des enquêtes mais
enquêtes qui sont plutôt d'ordre
administratives
d'autres enquêtes qui visent certains
établissements mais il y aura aussi des
groupes de des groupes d'études ou
peut-être même des commissions
gouvernementales qui se pencheront sur
l'ensemble des services de longue durée
que ce soit à domicile ou en
établissement merci beaucoup françois le
bilan d'avoir répondu à nos questions
rappelle que vous êtes professeur à
l'école de santé publique de
l'université de montréal